pour le groupe de l'union forces russes
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre au nom de
mon collègue gérard podium monsieur le
premier ministre en nouvelle calédonie
dans un contexte où l'écart entre
indépendantistes et non indépendantiste
s'est considérablement resserré lors du
référendum du 4 octobre dernier
valve a décidé de vendre son usine
métallurgique dans le sud du pays la
nouvelle calédonie s'est alors enflammée
l on a assisté à des scènes qui
rappellent les heures terribles des
événements des années 80 conscient de la
gravité de la situation nous étions
intervenus pour demander à ce que l'état
pilote désormais au plus haut niveau ce
dossier nous avions notamment suggéré
que le champ du dialogue soit ouvert
afin de construire un projet consensuel
pour la reprise de lusine au delà de
l'offre à l'origine du conflit
il nous avait alors été indiqué qu'il
n'y avait qu'une seule offre viable sur
la table et que le gouvernement la
soutenait depuis lors la situation
semble avoir évolué puisque mise d outre
mer a précisé dans ses voeux aux
calédoniens que le gouvernement fera une
nouvelle proposition très prochainement
prévoyant une implication plus forte de
l'état
nous ne pouvons que nous en féliciter
notre collègue gérard poggia les députés
calédoniens défendent est depuis
plusieurs semaines l'idée d'une
participation ou d'une prise de contrôle
temporaire de l'état au capital de valve
afin que les acteurs dispose du temps
nécessaire à la construction d'un
consensus politique industrielle sur la
poursuite de l'activité industrielle de
la capacité du gouvernement à donner est
véritablement corps à cette nouvelle
directive dépend le maintien de 3000
emplois le retour à la paix civile ainsi
que la reprise d'activité mais de cette
impulsion dépend surtout la reprise du
dialogue politique entre
indépendantistes et non indépendantiste
dialogue essentiel dans le cadre de la
préparation du troisième référendum
d'autodétermination prévu par l'accord
de nouméa
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est la suivante comment le gouvernement
entend t-il organiser lé implication
plus forte de l'état dans le dossier de
reprise de l'usiné du sud
je vous remercie
alors on est monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez la parole le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président longeau
et je m'adresse aussi sénateur poggia
est ce que vous l'avez citez dans votre
question je vous remercie de me donner
l'opportunité de m'exprimer ce dossier
extrêmement sensible et que je suis très
directement avec bien sûr le concours
très actif de sébastien lecornu ministre
chargé des outre-mer qui est ce dossier
de la nouvelle calédonie vous le savez
toutes et tous est d'ailleurs votre
question le rappelle opportunément la
question du nickel est dans ce
territoire une question hautement
stratégique
comme vous l'avez fait je rappelle à la
haute assemblée qui effectivement une
usine valve ou la vessie au sud de l'île
est actuellement en cours de cession
trois mille emplois sont concernés aux
seuls titres des salariés et des
sous-traitants un seul repreneur
vous l'avez dit et en lice l'état je le
rappelle au sénat intervient déjà très
massivement dans cette entreprise
au point qu'il a décidé de maintenir
cette aide au bénéfice de tout repreneur
jeu l'indiquent plus de 500 millions
d'euros sous forme de prêts et de
garanties de prêts et de défiscalisation
le projet de reprise
là vient la difficulté a fait l'objet
d'une opposition violente qui a conduit
à des troubles très grave dans l'île au
début du mois de décembre
la réponse de l'état par les forces de
l'ordre et d'autorité judiciaire a été
très clair et j'ajoute très bien
conduite et je veux le saluer devant la
haute assemblée
elle n'a malheureusement pas pu empêcher
de très nombreuses dégradations commises
dans cette usine et j'observe avec vous
qu'une partie des opposants au projet de
cession pourtant tout à fait
satisfaisant opposants qui sont plutôt
de tendance indépendantistes ont
finalement demandé la nationalisation de
lusine par l'état
le problème ne s'est malheureusement pas
arrêté là puisque d'autres opposants ont
également fait le choix de bloquer une
autre usine
vous connaissez la sln dont l'état est
actionnaire minoritaire via eramet est
là aussi pour le site met la pression
sur l'état dans le dossier de lusine du
sud objet de votre question en sorte que
cet autre usine était désormais au bord
de la faillite alors que dix mille
emplois
ils sont concerne je voudrais rappeler
du coup quelle est la politique du
gouvernement sur ces dossiers plus
généralement dans la sphère calédonienne
puisque tel est l'objet de votre
question c'est d'abord et toujours de
rechercher la voie du dialogue du diallo
le ministre d outre-mer a passé trois
semaines en nouvelle calédonie en
octobre tout de suite après la
consultation référendaire et il avait
après avoir rencontré tous les acteurs
réussi à mettre tout le monde autour de
la table
et justement le sujet du nickel sans
surprise faisait partie de l'échéancier
des concertations appelé à être conduite
en novembre et en décembre
évidemment trahi par visioconférence
pour les raisons que vous savez la
nouvelle calédonie n'étant pas épargnée
par la crise sanitaire
l'état fait des propositions pour faire
évoluer l'offre de l'entreprise rassurer
les populations locales et apaiser les
tensions
ces discussions mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs se poursuivent et les
autorités politiques locales compétentes
y sont associés pour mettre au point
définitivement les modalités de reprise
du site
son accompagnement par l'état qui se
poursuivra et son acceptabilité sociale
dans l'intérêt commun
mais pour pouvoir dialoguer je le dis
très tranquillement devant le sénat
encore faut-il réunir les conditions du
dialogue
c'est bien connu là bas comme partout on
ne dialogue pas monsieur sénateurs sous
la menace et les blocages en cours sur
les sites notamment de l'autre
in la sln je le dis devant vous doivent
cesser la paix civile l'ordre
républicain ne sont pas négociables ne
sont pas négociables et cette
affirmation
loin d'affaiblir la position est la
volonté du gouvernement de dialoguer au
contraire la renforce avec la tentation
de la violence
on ne peut ni transit zay ni tergiverser
de même je veux indiquer au sénat sur le
sénateur que les décisions de justice
qui ont été rendus ces dernières
semaines pour condamner les casseurs
doivent être appliquées et respectées si
on condamne les violences comme je me
plais à constater que d'aucuns le format
n'accepte que les auteurs des violences
soient condamnés et par ailleurs pour
dialoguer il faut que tout le monde soit
présent autour de la table je le redis
ici publiquement la tribune du sénat
tout en étant ferme sur le respect de
certains principes
je continue inlassablement le
gouvernement continue inlassablement à
appeler autour de la table l'ensemble
des responsables politiques de l'île
monsieur le sénateur vous avez fait le
parallèle avec les terribles violences
qui ont marqué la nouvelle calédonie au
début des années 1980 mais je crois que
nous devons résister à cette tentation
d'un fermer cette ce territoire dans
cette référence
le contexte n'est plus du tout le même
trente années de rééquilibrage de
partage du pouvoir de dialogues sont
passés par là surtout surtout mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs aujourd'hui
la moitié de la population du caillou à
moitié a moins de 30 ans à moins de 30
ans voilà donc la responsabilité
historique devant laquelle la république
et l'ensemble des acteurs politiques
tels calédoniens se trouve non pas
reproduire revenir vers ce passé que
vous avez évoquées dans votre question
mais inventer une solution politique
nouvelle pour la calédonie dans le cadre
de la république
16 vous pouvez compter sur l'engagement
de mon gouvernement dans ce projet
merci monsieur le premier ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons terminé que
les questions au gouvernement
merci monsieur le premier ministre dames
et messieurs les ministres nos
prochaines questions auront lieu le 20
janvier
la séance est suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h45 notamment pour la
désignation des membres de deux missions
d'information et le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport de la commission
d' enquête sur les problèmes sanitaires
et écologiques liés aux pollutions des
sols
la séance est suspendue